I'll film raise my spirit back welcome
to PewDiePie we're gonna do the last
level so I replay this game three times
I didn't realize there was a save game
feature and then and when I realized it
I click load game and I reset the game
again so I had to replay it like filt
don't leash it know by right well
playing what did they hurt you if you
walked into fire in real life you can
walk on others just it that was just a
test just a test you think you guys just
too tight I'm so sorry I spit all over
you can i what the [ __ ] was that step
second walk through those why do I get
sucked up this is not gravity main
center Bullock is nowhere to be found
except maybe she's that thing actually
nevermind what was that oh [ __ ] okay how
do I do this then oh god super gravity
Sandra Bullock [ __ ] am I supposed to do
then oh okay I got it I got it
well [ __ ] you in the ass then oh yes but
choppa okay I don't know what I did but
I did it alright so let's go with logic
here they want me to jump up that's what
they won met it though but that's not
what I'm gonna do I'm gonna
never by then all right jump on the
clown's ass [ __ ]
hey cloudy oh my god there we go
keep crawling you son of a [ __ ] you ILS
[ __ ] clown oh god oh god oh god
George like your ass is really bouncing
man it's just like my ass is made out of
rubber yes [ __ ]
why sir clown there I might jump on em
just for a good luck what keep walking
Ruben keep walking all right you dyed
roof oh I died
ah oh my god I hate everything and
everyone shut up gasps but I don't know
what the [ __ ] me I hate this game no no
gasps aah
it's after 8:00 [ __ ] it up ha ha don't
shine go go go go go go go go yup what
and God he's pooping on my carpet get
Evan move fast you
oh go oh yeah get away from me
alright alright come at me bro damn
goodnight [ __ ]
Danya that that way no alright just walk
down there's definitely a trap here
stuff another try
it's easy [ __ ] kids yeah for [ __ ]
sake man go no no no no no can you move
a little slower please I can't contain
all these patients I'm a funny hand the
best better denied what a brute all
right here we go run run run run run
watch out for the clown don't forget
about the clown don't fall yeah
don't forget are the clowns hello la
valeur mousse if it damn I'm a whole
chef they know ah
what what was that Gandalf go go go
alright watch this for us first try
[Laughter]
great I'm turning red in the game and in
real life there's almost as realistic as
to connect watch this last try don't you
[ __ ] me I'll [ __ ] you actually no I
won't
I'm not into clowns ah alright just jump
over this [ __ ] yes yes oh you just had
to come back how do I make this jump now
oh there we go
a [ __ ] penis really what is that how
do I deny the penis like this okay I got
it
I've been at it nope got my heel how do
wait there we go deny the penis and deny
life all right it's no [ __ ] way I can
do that job ma'am and they looked
Mandell aunt the flora sugar span
Montara logged that what them reflexes
the [ __ ] [ __ ] alright taste
it you [ __ ] make boys on it's never
been this on ah I forgot about the
[ __ ] trapping block what do you want
from me do I look like a memory block I
know I'll go home you don't know
the Benia about a Betty's Ibarra [ __ ]
jump [ __ ] you - Baroness now Tyra it
[ __ ] you ferret it and they look and
they look man and a look the long Manon
flan sugar spend no shop I can elbow a
little for that oh alright it's gonna
move right how many times you gonna move
the eye one time one time [ __ ] you in
the ass I'm sorry I'll stop swearing
[ __ ]
move [ __ ] I spit everywhere never go
there we go there we go oh there we go
my bro a yo ho go why do I do I even
though I don't touch it it's just like
real life except not really
Oh what oh my god I'm a genius [ __ ] me
then hey I lost my duck feet
how am I supposed to fly what Oh Nona
clouds [ __ ] in the clouds
sorry it's still on your face
night night what is this hey you again I
don't have time to read you oh my god
what is this
no god oh god don't kill me oh god
please don't kill me
please ignore me Oh goddamn I hate this
[ __ ] beginning I hate it with a
passion
watch out for the clown ah hey again you
have gather bananas around here I give
them I'm hungry food Oh for [ __ ] sake
I read him I read your stupid message
why do I have to be punished why Rueben
save me [ __ ] you Ruben [ __ ] yo how would
I jump so so had it looked there look
Manon they will not say that's gonna oh
please come here already
don't worry Danny Felix this godly soul
all y'all so send Tommy then she's just
a hot I actually found my tablet oh how
did a jab lateral head Victor step
ninja block clown picked up more water
you know wall buddy it up buddy you know
vomit you know boy lighting it up I'm
gonna get up I'm gonna get up how am I
supposed to [ __ ] a clown when I had it
all god I'm just gonna keep going a
banana
alright two bananas oh my god I can't
collect they're too many bananas it's
just not my style man collect the damn
banana Raul [ __ ] you up
goddamn I hate but oh god dammit so many
bananas oh god don't come up here thank
you sir appreciate their quarry or
cropper coop coop collaboration
cooperation something that was a word in
there go up go up don't [ __ ] me
he [ __ ] me just look how I can't do it
I just can't there's no chance at all
that I can do it he just comes here and
what am I supposed to do have you ever
heard of bananas they were invented for
people like you who has no self-respect
go up I say go up I shake Dodgers all
right go for the bananas we can do it
how am I supposed to do it how am I
supposed to do with that oh my god aah
oh my god I got it yeah all right aah
how many [ __ ] but is this a bad need
to take do I look like a [ __ ] to you oh
definitely busker Busker what's going on
otherwise I may finish her God Oh God I
don't think it's friendly oh oh oh oh
sit down sit down sit down
Snoop Dogg
it's on it's on Donkey Kong race
Donkey Kong race i'ma eat your banana
right in your face
Donkey Kong [ __ ] don't [ __ ] me [ __ ] me
stop don't talk to me
loser lamer wannabe [ __ ] you
this is my banana why can't I grab it oh
my God give me them in a towel ready oh
my god just got the banana
oh great oh great I'll faint [ __ ]
curse